welcome back to new rockstars i'm eric
voss and secret invasion is the marvel
crossover event making my
many mcu scroll searches after captain
marvel and spider-man apart from home
not a total waste of time kevin feige's
announcement last month confirmed it
folks
some person or persons that we have
known in the mcu beyond nick fury maria
hill
is a scroll imposter marvel's one
division is launching this multiverse
saga
this week and i actually think more
secret invasion seeds are being planted
in the series
that we need to keep an eye out for
those of you tired of me saying
everything in one of mission is methysto
that you can relax
now everything is scrolls because i'm
dragging one evision through my other
indulgent tinfoil party
a scroll search
and this video was brought to you by
squarespace from websites and online
stores to marketing tools and analytics
squarespace is the all-in-one platform
to build a beautiful online presence and
run your business
after reports of a nick fury disney plus
series in the works earlier last year
feige confirmed my theory that this was
actually a secret invasion series
secret invasion next to civil war secret
invasion is arguably the biggest
crossover comic event in the last 20
years
it's about a sect of scrolls who have
infiltrated every level of life on earth
every level of life on earth peggy haha
very choice words hinting that that
infiltration includes
organizations like shield and the
avengers
now of course the scrolls have
infiltrated shield we saw that in
captain marvel squirrels impersonated
agent coulson
and taylor's posed as fury's boss keller
and we know fury's scroll partnership
continued in secret through the years
because spider-man apart from home ended
by revealing that version of fury was
talos the whole time
he told peter parker that mysterio was
from earth just not
yours mr beck is from earth
just not yours as in he's not from
earth he and maria hill briefly discuss
cree sleeper cells
i thought cree having sleeper cells was
top-secret information
referring to some ongoing covert war
between the cree
and the scrolls and then of course the
post-credits scene shows fury and hill
freaking reverting back to
the squirrels taylors and his wife soren
while the real fury was kicking back on
the space station with a bunch of
squirrels who took his shoes
i immediately identified this as the
peak the orbital space station
headquarters of sword
sentient world observation and response
department sword doesn't have a ton of
operations with the skulls in the comics
and it's actually run by abigail brandt
not nick fury but
in the mcu it seems sword is a kind of
offshoot of shield
after shield fell following its
corruption by hydra some
secret contingency that nick fury fled
to after
burning his bridge with shield and
winter soldier we can assume that sword
was a side project that nick fury had
for a while
because that pager that he exchanged
with captain marvel the one that he used
to summon her at the end of infinity war
was later revealed to have
a sword crest on the back of it and now
a sword looks to be playing a very big
role in one division premiering this
friday
sword is the organization monitoring
wanda in her west view pocket reality it
includes former fbi agent jimmy wu from
ant-man of the wasp
astrophysicist darcy lewis from the thor
movies and monica rambo grown up from
the young girl she was in the captain
marvel film early footage shows the
sword crest popping up all over juan
division
on the back of the suit of the beekeeper
who climbs up through the manhole
on the toy helicopter wanda finds which
we think might be that life-size
helicopter warped into a harmless
toy and many of you rightly pointed out
that monica's necklace is obviously
another sword logo
wow i missed that one the fact that
monica is involved with the same skrull
aligned organization that nick fury
appears to be connected to
forces us to go back and look at
monica's first close encounter with
these extraterrestrials playing
uno at her louisiana rambo home with
taylor's daughter
put that card down you guys have the
best eyes don't ever change your eyes
oh a clue we didn't get a very clear
look at the eyes of this young scroll
girl earlier on the scroll ship
wide with fear in an interesting
close-up reaction shot after her father
as a greased soldier shot the other
creep cover her
eyes
[Music]
under the ship let's go let's go now i
always thought something more was gonna
come from that
but now it seems like a loose end
setting up a future of this friendship
which we could see
with the adult sword agent monica rambo
in wanda vision
especially since as i saw in my trailer
breakdown last year the scene in which
monica gets ejected from west view
shows a second monika approaching with
the other agents
i know you're gonna say this is just
edited from two different scenes
but in the close-up of monica laying in
the grass you can see the headlights of
the trucks that
the other monika rolls up in behind her
two monikas so is this
all setting up the events of secret
invasion
and again thanks to squarespace for
sponsoring this video squarespace is the
all-in-one platform to build a beautiful
online presence and run your business
are you looking to sell your wares you
want the world to be able to appreciate
your replica wolverine claws and
appreciate how they're sharp enough to
really hurt yourself
present your claws and any of your other
work to the world using squarespace's
professional portfolio designs display
projects and customizable galleries
and add password protected pages to
share private work with clients you can
auto post your content to twitter
facebook or tumblr they have built-in
mobile websites and a
really slick mailing list feature to
stay in touch with your customers
firespace will even sell you
a url you know somebody checked to see
if boobsmyclaws.com is available
if it is squarespace we'll sell it head
to squarespace.com for a free trial and
when you're ready to launch go to
squarespace.com
new rockstars to save 10 off your first
purchase of a website or a domain
that's squarespace.comrockstars for 10
off your first purchase of a website or
a domain
so on this channel we have done a number
of scroll searches
including a super deep dive into pretty
much every name in the mcu in an episode
of the big question
our investigation concluded that beyond
nick fury and maria hill whom we already
know about
the likeliest mcu characters to either
be skrull imposters themselves or to
have squirrel doubles whom they work in
tandem with
are the be cast government workers
without
clearly defined on-screen origin stories
but
faces who have seemingly always been
there on the periphery
for whom it'd be pretty dramatic to see
revealed as scrolls
sharon carter secretary of state
thaddeus ross hank pym
even howard stark i know when howard
stark died we didn't see him revert to a
scroll but i would say the camera did
quickly cut away from his final breaths
and
i could see the mcu suddenly no longer
really holding itself to that reversion
rule like they've retconned over crazier
plot holes before that's why new
rockstars is here to make videos
explaining how it all kinda actually
makes sense meanwhile the marquee
avengers names like cap hulk spider-man
they're less likely to be scrolls
because as superheroes their
skrull imposters to mirror their powers
would have to be what's called super
scrolls which
are a thing but on screen i would see
that kind of taking away some of the
uniqueness of those heroes
in the mcu but a lot of the avengers are
relatively normal human beings just with
super advanced
tech folks like sam wilson falcon
natasha romanov maybe
jim rhodes war machine a guy who has
literally
changed faces look it's me i'm here
deal with it let's move on but given
rhodey's injury in civil war
i doubt he would have stayed in his
broken human form for that whole process
boom you looking for this folks when
we're identifying scroll suspects
a lot of these people could be scrolls
but it's more helpful to look at who
would be scrolls for working with
scrolls like along with fury who
else has relationships with the squirrel
for which it would be valuable to
partner with them i think
this little overlooked moment in captain
marvel was the setup for a similar
scroll partnership between monica rambo
and taylor's daughter partners
in deceit one theory i presented after
far from home is that maria hill's
relatively recent rise through the
shield ranks
nebulous backstory and the fact that
unlike fury we never saw where the real
hill was after sworn was revealed apart
from home
all this poses the possibility that
there might never have really been
a human maria hill but rather maria hill
was the human form of sorin and that
talos all this time served as
fury's double so that mcfury could kind
of be in multiple places at one you need
to keep
both eyes open i think we can extend
that theory
to talos's daughter as a friend of
monica rambo as these two girls both
rise up through the ranks of sword
imagine a scenario in one division where
monica defies jimmy wu's orders to
stay away from the border of this town
of west view for their own safety but
monica
sneaks into the town with her scroll
friend posing as her on the outside so
that no one would know monica had gone
but then when monica is suddenly ejected
from wanda's dream
monica 2 is right there and uh
wow game over man there's some real
pretty [ __ ] now
man so the only thing we need to make
this make sense is which familiar face
has that female scroll been
all the other time well a solid suspect
sharon carter sharon carter is returning
shortly after wanna vision in the falcon
in the winter soldier and there is a lot
we don't know about her she
is sneaky always spying on cap and even
cap didn't know that she was related to
peggy carter in fact maybe that whole
great granny's identity was really just
a cover story to help this scroll blend
into society the secret invasion of the
comics posed these scrolls as the
antagonist they're enemy
aliens invading the ranks of human
society in order to bring down earth but
the mcu secret invasion is going to be a
lot more complex
squirrels are the good guys in the mcu
they work with fury to try to help
protect earth from the imperialist cree
those pre-sleeper cells that's what
that's all about but in order to help
protect earth they have to hide and
blend in
in the ranks but knowing how humans
think that reveal ain't gonna go over
well
humanity loves to demonize those not in
our tribes so that's what the secret
innovation is going to be
humans versus scrolls even those girls
are just trying to help us to protect us
from the real enemy
decree that is how we get an mcu secret
invasion crisis
hopefully sometime next year on disney
plus and it's all going to start with
monica rambo in wanda vision in the
weeks ahead
mark my words actually don't work and i
can't handle another what we got wrong
hey support this channel by checking out
our great merch options including our
new
latest obsession custom one division
shirts with hidden visuals revealed via
augmented reality at
newrockstarsmerch.com
getting one of these babies gives you
the option to write custom shout outs
that we will feature
in our inside marvel wanna vision after
show that is coming this friday right
after the premiere on disney plus and of
course my easter egg breakdown will come
out the next day
follow me at eavos follow new rockstars
subscribe to rockstars here on youtube
subscribe to inside marvel wherever you
get your podcast
thank you for watching and remember if
you are a scroll you legally have to
tell
[Music]
foreign
[Music]